Onto rows, Power Query gives us a number of options for correcting rows,
such as removing rows based on specific logic,
which includes removing all rows where the values are blank or removing alternate rows,
which can be very helpful if you're using some sort of pre-structured report like
a Crystal Report that has output with every other row being blank,
can come in very, very handy.
You can also specify the top and bottom of rows to make sure that the rows
that you're removing are specific to exactly the number that you know need to go away.
You can promote headers.
This is where if the column names are showing up as values in row 1,
you can also take that first row
and tell Power Query to push them up into the header level,
and you can remove duplicates based on the values in a specific row.
This can be helpful if you're dealing with a key column on a dimension table,
say someone input a specific PLU code for our grocery store twice by mistake,
like what we saw with the Granny Smith Apple issue,
and we just need one to be available.
We just use that to delete otherwise identical information.
You can also remove rows that contain errors,
and you can do so in a specific column,
or you can do it in any column that contains errors,
but I do recommend caution with most row transformations.
Unlike with columns, do hesitate
to delete rows if you're not sure whether they're needed,
you need to be careful here because it's really easy to skew
the data without it being immediately obvious to those reviewing your report.
It's still easy to undo a row tidying step just as it is for columns,
but with columns, the field's either there or it isn't.
With rows, it may take some time to realize
something's at miss and then address the error.
Take care with deleting rows with errors or duplicates, please.
With all that said, delete your blank rows.